>> IT'S THE CUOMOS STARRING
ANDREW AND CHRIS.
>> Greg: EXCUSES ARE NOT SO
HOT, AS CHRIS CUOMO HEADS FOR
THE YACHT.
FOX NEWS CAUGHT UP WITH CHRIS
CUOMO AT A HAMPTONS DOCK BEFORE
I HAD A CHANCE TO REMOVE HIS
SHIRT TO SHOW OFF HIS PACKS.
MIKE IS MEDIUM-SIZE POLO, YOU
KNOW HE SHRUNK IT ON PURPOSE,
HIS LIPS WERE TIGHT.
>> HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO YOUR
BROTHER TODAY, SIR?
>> OF COURSE.
>> ARE YOU CONTINUING TO ADVISE
HIM.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S AN ETHICAL
CONFLICT?
>> I THINK YOU'VE GOT A JOB TO
DO AND I'M LETTING YOU DO IT.
>> IS YOUR BROTHER COMING TO
EAST HAMPTON?
>> YES.
IF YOU WAIT HERE, HE'LL BE HERE
IN 5 MINUTES.
>> Greg: SEE, THAT'S FUNNY.
THAT'S FUNNY.
PUT THAT IN MY MONOLOGUE.
AT LEAST HE HAS FINALLY LEARNED
TO CONTROL HIS TEMPER, RIGHT?
>> RUIN YOUR BLEED.
THROW YOU DOWN THE STAIRS LIKE A
[BLEEP].
>> Greg: SEE, HE'S CHANGED.
SOMEONE WHO NEVER LOSE HIS
COMPOSURE UNLESS IT'S AROUND
KRISPY KREME'S.
BRIAN STELTER.
PERFECT COMPANY MAN.
ARE YOU APPLAUDING HIM OR THE
JOKE?
HE DEFENDED CNN'S HANDLING OF
THE CUOMO CRISIS ON COLBERT.
>> "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THAT'S TRUE.
CHRIS WAS HELPING HIS BROTHER.
HAS IT CREATED ANY CONFLICT AT
CNN BEHIND CLOSE DOORS?
ARE PEOPLE MAD AT HIM?
IS HE IN TROUBLE QUESTION MIGHT
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE MAD AT HIM.
I HAVE A SOURCE THAT SINCE CHRIS
WAS ON THE PHONE WITH HIS
BROTHER THIS WEEK.
>> IS YOUR SOURCE NAMED CUOMO?
>> IT IS NOT.
YOU NEED TO HAVE BOUNDARIES.
YOU NEED TO DRAW A LINE.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE BOUNDARIES.
>> DOES.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE GOVERNOR.
>> Greg: HE SAID THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE JOURNALISM ETHICS
BOOKS ON HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
SITUATION.
I GUESS IT DOESN'T HAVE A
SECTION ON "DUH" EITHER.
NICE TO HEAR SOMEONE MENTION
BOUNDARIES WHEN TALKING ABOUT
THE CUOMOS.
LIMITED CHUCK TODD.
>> HIS CAREER WAS EITHER
PERMANENTLY OVER OUR ALMOST
PERMANENTLY OVER AND HE CHOSE
THE PATH ALMOST PERMANENTLY
OVER.
I EXPECT IN MY LIFETIME
ANDREW CUOMO TO PROBABLY RUN FOR
OFFICE AGAIN.
>> Greg: CHUCK HAD ONLY GOT
FIVE YEARS TO LIVE.
BUT THE BODY IS NOT EVEN COLD
YEAR.
TUCKER CARLSON PROPOSED
INTERESTING THEORY ABOUT THE
NEW YORK AG.
>> SHE SAID THE AG.
HE THOUGHT IT MEANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SHE SAID IT STANDS FOR ASPIRING
GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE REASONS TO QUESTION
LETITIA JAMES' MOTIVES TO PUT IT
MILDLY.
>> Greg: LIKE MY PHONE NUMBER
ON A TRUCK STOP BATHROOM, THE
WRITING WAS ON THE WALL FOR THE
GOVERNOR.
BY THE WAY WHEN YOU DO CALL THE
NUMBER, SPECIFY ROUTE AND
LOCATION.
I'M NOT GOING TO DRIVE AROUND
FOREVER.
TUCKER HAS ECHOED WHAT I'VE
HEARD A LOT WHICH IS CUOMO IS A
CREEP BUT WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE
WHAT'S COMING IN.
YOU COULD GET EL de BLASIO AS
GOVERNOR.
HE WOULD GET LETITIA JAMES.
IS IT BETTER TO HAVE A LESS
CRAZY CREEP THAN THE NONCREEP
WHO IS A HARD-CORE LEFTIST?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Matt: I'M HAVING TROUBLE
WITH THE LOGIC.
I'M GLAD HE'S GONE.
I THINK THERE'S A SPECIAL PLACE
AT CNN FOR EVERY FAILED NEW YORK
POLITICIAN.
I COULD SEE A REBOUND OF THE
MAN'S CAREER FOR SURE.
AND I THINK THE THING MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE THAT'S GROSS IS TO
SEE BRIAN STELTER SAY WHO HIS
SOURCES ARE NOT.
ANONYMOUS MEANS YOU'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT YOUR SOURCES.
YOU DON'T SAY KEEP COMING WITH
THE NAMES.
I WILL TELL YOU WHEN YOU'RE
GETTING WARMER.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW THAT WITH
HIM IT WAS CUOMO.
KAT, COULD THERE BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BROTHERS TO
HAVE THEIR OWN SHOW?
VERY POPULAR AMONG THE MEDIA
WHEN THAT HAPPENED.
>> Kat: A BOAT SHOW.
PEOPLE ARE MISSING A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE STORY
WHICH IS THE NAME OF CHRIS
CUOMO'S BOAT IS HEART STRONG.
OKAY, BUDDY.
WHO NAMES THE BOAT THAT?
IT'S LIKE A MOVIE ABOUT A
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL TEAM.
HE IS NOT THE GUY HE THINKS HE
IS AND ALSO IT BLOWS THE WHOLE
PLAN VACATION THING OUT OF THE
WATER.
WHO MAKES MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR AND PLANS A VACATION TO
STAY HOME?
NOBODY.
>> Greg: WHEN YOUR HOME IS THE
HAMPTONS.
>> Kat: I WOULDN'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> Greg: JOE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS?
IS THE STORY ONGOING OR IS IT
ABOUT A FLAMEOUT?
>> Joe: THERE'S A LOT TO IT.
FOR CHRIS CUOMO, IF YOUR
NICKNAME IS FREDO, DON'T GO ON
ANY BOATS.
HE IS IN THE HAMPTONS.
HIS BROTHER IS EVIDENT IN BY
HIMSELF.
HARASSING HIMSELF OUT OF
LONELINESS.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, YOU KNOW I
GET MY POLITICAL PREDICTIONS
FROM CNN AND FROM CELEBRITIES.
I MISCALCULATED.
THEY TOLD ME IN 2020 THAT
ANDREW CUOMO WAS GOING TO BE THE
NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, AND I SPENT ALL
MY MONEY MAKING THESE BUMPER
STICKERS.
CUOMO-MICHAEL AVENATTI 2024.
TRYING TO UNLOAD THEM.
I THINK THESE MIGHT MOVE, I HAD
THEM EDIT THEM AT THE PRINT
SHOP.
THEY HAVE A HANDCUFFS ON.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD
EDITORIAL CARTOON.
>> Matt: ARE WE ALLOWED TO
BRING PROPS QUESTION McKAY
DIDN'T KNOW THIS.
>> Joe: MY LESSONS FROM LAST
TIME.
2012.
>> Greg: HE HAS BEEN CARRYING
THAT AROUND FOR EIGHT YEARS.
>> Joe: I HAVE HAD IN MY
BACKPACK.
>> Greg: IT'S GOT A YOGURT
STAIN ON IT.
>> Susan: THE NIKE SIGN FOR
AVENATTI?
>> Greg: I ASKED THE QUESTIONS
HERE.
>> Susan: THINK OF
CORPORATIONS.
>> Greg: WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN TO
CHRIS CUOMO?
>> Susan: THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHY I'M SITTING HERE.
>> Susan: I DON'T WANT TO MAKE
ANY JUDGMENTS ON ANY FELLOW
PEERS, JOURNALIST RAY DIDN'T HE
USED TO WORK HERE?
DID YOU KNOW HIM?
>> Greg: WE WERE ROOMMATES.
WE COULDN'T FIND A PLACE TO LIVE
SO WE STATED A WOMEN'S COLLEGE.
WE DRESSED UP AS WOMEN.
DID YOU WATCH THE RESIGNATION?
I LOVE THAT THE CHYRON'S WERE
STILL BEHIND.
5 MINUTES BEHIND BEFORE THEY
SAID CUOMO RESIGNED.
EVERYONE WAS CHECKING, DID HE
REALLY SAY THAT?
WOW.
EVERYONE'S DOUBLE CHECKING AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> Greg: KAT, WHAT DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT CHUCK TODD SAYING THAT
THERE COULD BE A COME BACK?
>> Kat: I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
WOULD POSSIBLY LEAD TO THAT.
BASED ON WHAT EVIDENCE?
HE RESIGNED.
THIS WAS ALL REALLY BAD.
HE'S A BAD GUY.
BUT THERE IS STILL ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS THAT HE DID.
>> Greg: THE NURSING HOME.
>> Kat: PRIORITY TESTING FOR
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
I LOSE TRACK, SO MANY HORRIBLE
THINGS.
MISUSING THE FUNDS FOR THE BOOK.
WHAT A WEIRD HILL TO DIE ON.
WHY, CHUCK TODD?
MAYBE HE GOT THE TEST.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
HE COULD STILL RUN AGAIN AS
GOVERNOR